now for the other side we welcome in
former Baltimore Mayor Stephanie
rawlings-blake madam mayor thanks for
being here your thoughts you just heard
that from the former acting White House
chief of staff the state of the race
where you see it tonight I I think it's
always great to be up in the polls but
the most important poll we know is
election day I think so many of us
remember the pain that we felt knowing
the polls were favoring Hillary Clinton
four years ago and knowing the the
ultimate outcome and I hope everyone
understands the the price that is paid
when we don't go to the polls so I I
encourage people even though we're we
are pleased and the the Biden team is
pleased that the the polls are showing
him ahead that we cannot take it for
granted the focus needs to be on making
sure that every single Democrat gets out
to vote because if that happens Bimal
win yeah there is some frustration up on
Capitol Hill Republicans thought that
they were close to at least starting the
conversation on police reform take a
listen to Senator Tim Scott on this
young Americans of all colors are losing
faith in the institutions of authority
and power in this nation because we're
playing small ball or playing for those
in the insulated chambers we're playing
for presidential politics so Democrats
blocked the effort to even get the bill
to the to vote on or to be amended and
there's frustration that this is all
about politics and trying to be a
presidential issue how do you respond to
that I think it's definitely frustrating
for many of us to see what's going on in
Congress
our hope my hope is that some meaningful
police reform will come out of Congress
but what I know from being a mayor is a
lot of the leadership happens on the
ground level from mayors and I know that
police reform is something that mayor's
across the country are taking a look at
they are engaging with their
constituents to make sure that the
policing for their community fits what
the community needs so I'm while I know
that it's frustrating that the reform
isn't coming out of Capitol Hill that
doesn't mean that change isn't coming so
you would tell your Democrat colleagues
on the hill maybe they should have gone
forward and and tried to amend the bill
and get 70% not 100% you know I wouldn't
you know I think it's important for them
to stand their ground in the way that
they think is important they're there
every day they know what they need to
get done for me while it's frustrating
that there isn't more coming out of it
what I know is that you know as much as
they're doing the real change happens on
the ground it's the work that they're
doing in Congress isn't going to change
the law enforcement bill of law
enforcement officers Bill of Rights in
Maryland which had to be amended to make
sure that my police commissioner could
enforce and take precautions when it was
necessary against officers who had
committed wrongdoing yeah I want to play
just one more sound by for you and this
is Bob Johnson the founder of the et
talking to Fox earlier this week Vice
President Biden said to African America
black American hosts on a show even if
you think about voting for Donald Trump
you're not black to have that mindset
you must have the attitude that we black
Americans we own you we can take you for
granted that to me shows you that black
Americans are an appendage of a party
what I would say that maybe black lives
matter should start its own party what's
your response to Bob Johnson I think
it's unfortunate that he took what Biden
said you know when prompted by a radio
host out of context and did so you know
unfortunately to be more divisive and I
don't think it's a time for us as a
community to to think about being
divisive
the Democratic Party has always been a
place where african-americans you know
in my lifetime has found opportunities
for leadership I was the the secretary
for the DNC you know there's so many
that have gone before me so to say that
because of something that was in
artfully said on a talk show that
african-americans are an opinion of the
party I don't I don't believe that to be
the case at all yeah just last thing
quickly I mean you're saying not to be
divisive but there are parts of this
movement and tearing down monuments and
statues beyond Confederate figures that
some would say are divisive and outside
the norm of our process of government
will the vice president former vice
president speak out about that I think
what we need to hear is our president
speak out he has against against racism
against police brutality he spent more
time defending these monuments of the
south monuments of the Confederates that
were anti America anti us he spent more
time defending then that he has
protecting the over a hundred and
thousand of over a hundred thousand
Americans that have died from kovat you
know he's got his priorities really
mixed up I think if he focused on you
know listening to the to the protesters
instead of trying to incite violence and
you know to try to boost his his poll
numbers with his base I think we'd all
be better off yeah obviously the Trump
campaign has a different view of where
he is and what he said
mayor we appreciate your time please
send the message that we'd love to have
the former vice president on will do
thanks